الان بدات هذه الاشتباكات مره اخرى على
مشارك بدايه الهدنه الهدنه لم يتبقى لها
سوى اقل من نصف ساعه لتبدا ابنه 24 ساعه
انطلقت هذه الاشتباك الان في مناطق الريق
نحن هنا في منطقه لنستمع الى هذه المضادات
مضادات الطائرات في منطقه معسكر الشمبا في
الجهه الغربيه
اسمح لي فقط تتحدث عن طيران
هذه مضادات للطائرات هذه الاصوات التي
اسمعها لكن لا اسمع صوت الطيارات او
الطائرات التي تستهلك لكن هذه الاصوات
تشبه اصوات مضادات الطائرات التي يستمع
اليها الان
مضادات لطائرات نفهم بان هناك كذلك اما
مروحيات استطلاع او طائرات
هجوميه في سماء الخرطوم في هذه الاثناء
الى جانب المدفعيه الثقيله على الارض صحيح
سالم
اسمه هذه صوت المد
منتشر مختلفه في منطقه بحر الان في غرب
بحري وشرق بحري كذلك في منطقه
مستمع الى هذه ايضا
المضادات وكذلك اصوات لمدافع ثقيله كذلك
في اتجاه الخرطوم كذلك هنالك اصوات لمدافع
في هذه اللحظات كل هذا ابين الانطلاق هذه
الهدنه التي تريد ان تنطلق في السادسه من
مساء اليوم
24 ساعه وافق عليها الطلب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات